i had conversations with my brother
i always have conversations with my
brother because he's my brother and he's
my best friend
and obviously he was aware of what was
going on
he was not covering the story he had
recused himself
that's new york governor andrew cuomo
now defending his cnn anchor brother
chris cuomo for
advising him on his various scandals
including sexual harassment allegations
but the three-term democrat also said
quote-unquote i talk to journalists
about situations all the time and they
tell me their thoughts and their advice
meanwhile fox news contributor joe
koncha torched chris cuomo
on outnumbered yesterday
chris cuomo is fiercely loyal to his
family okay
go work for your brother then you
already do already might as well get
paid for that aspect
that's what's unbelievable about this
right or go work for the dnc
or run for office yourself he's getting
criticized by the left by the way this
isn't a right
wing argument or a left-wing argument
it's a pragmatic argument
power panel now tammy bruce is here
president of independent women's voice
and
richard fowler is here radio talk show
host both fox news contributors great to
see you guys
so tammy when i hear the governor saying
that he gets advice and talks to
with other journalists now i'm curious
about why cnn isn't investigating and
publicly saying that because were these
other journalists at cnn
well you know i think harris that this
is not unusual we've now grown used to
this it can't just be that network
we know that it is the broadcast
networks we know msdnc has an issue
we know that newspapers have issues it's
why
there's a distrust of legacy media
because we see this revolving door as
well
whether it's jake tapper who was a
democrat operative on capitol hill many
people do not know that
of course george stephanopoulos uh and
it becomes difficult because you see
that they don't cover the news really
it really is an opinion network they
should just admit
that they're an opinion network and then
of course chris cuomo has his other
issues when it came to when he had covet
uh you know telling people that he's
buried in his basement and he's isolated
and then we find out that was untrue as
well so americans are making their
choice
they're not choosing that particular
network and i think that that is the
message that americans can send
about what information they consume who
they support so even
liberals have stopped watching that
network and
uh for as far as the governor i mean the
smug
horrible attitude that continues that
nothing matters except what affects him
what he thinks
the choices he makes under multiple
federal
and state investigations because of his
attitude
he feels so imperious that none of it
matters
of course he's going to have that
attitude and of course that's fed in
part harris
by support from the media and he thinks
that's going to protect him